everyone today of the workshop so within
that ii thought by jason in the minute i
just wanted to announce a change in the
schedule so this afternoon we're gonna
have not cheat twice in a row and as an
unspoken generative model will be to
more money this afternoon is twice okay
in the second part today i'm going to
start talking about how to move towards
more algorithmic results rather than
geometric or topological in nature in
particular all of the algorithmic
results i present will be about a single
algorithm whether g-d or SGD can find
solutions of low training error and low
test error so I'll first go over some
earlier work on random features and how
they're related to carve to neural
networks and then about more recent work
on the connection between neural nets
and kernel methods called neural tangent
kernels and their limitations
okay so let's step back a little like
I've shown you that with the
second-order stationary points and
topological results second-order station
importance are very limited the only
models that have any hope of being where
a second-order stationary points are
good is really when you only have a
single hidden layer and essentially
activations that are quadratic or maybe
monomial and similarly with the
topological argument it's quite unlikely
that you can just using that you can
prove an algorithmic result so let's
look back to when we do have algorithmic
results with just a tiny bit of work the
first one is in a random features model
essentially random features is where you
fix the hidden layer and only optimize
the output layer so optimization is
essentially free there the optimization
of the output layer is a convex problem
and you clearly will get training error
0 and the second area is a local result
where you have this sort of poly AK
gradient domination condition you can
establish this even in over parametrize
results so
turns out you can kind of combine these
two ideas and still say something okay
so we're going to try to use these two
building blocks so here's a review of
random features we're going to look at a
family of this family of functions
defined with respect to integration of a
base function Phi there's going to be a
measure C of theta and then so f is
going to be the integral of Phi C of
theta D Omega of theta Omega is just
some base measure for convenience you
can think of theta as uniform on the
sphere so Omega is a uniform measure on
the sphere Phi of X theta is perhaps an
activation function and see if theta is
some sine measure on the sphere okay so
functions of this form where you put
some constraint on the C of theta is
induces of an arc AHS these functions
are the completion of this family of
functions is the same as the arc HS
induced by the following Cardinal okay
so how is this related at all to deep
learning well the first thing the notice
is that if you're very very wide you can
start replacing sums with integrals
right so if this is my to learn network
and I have am going to infinity then it
sort of looks like some integral I can
just sort of by pattern-matching I just
write as an integral so if it was finite
width I would just let C of theta be a
scaling of the Dirac Delta function and
I just put doubters or wherever WJ is on
the sphere I normalize let's use
homogeneous activation so then I
normalize the W's and then move all of
their norms to the assigned measure okay
so roughly speaking when M is very large
anything in this space anything of that
type can be written as a to learn
network or in fact a to learn network is
is at least as expressive as this
current as this arc HS okay so here's a
function from Rahimi and rec that
basically says this if I have a function
f that's written as in this integral
form then I can approximate it with a
finite number of bases so there exists
some f hat which consists of only m of
these basis elements and I've hat and F
are close it's roughly something order
of 1 over square root m so not only does
it exist
it's Rahimi Iraq gave of simple
construction the construction is you
simply sample Thetas uniform from the
measure Omega and you fit the A's oh
this is by Barron Jones not ok sorry or
Mori but the arc HS connection is Rahimi
rekt the connection to RHS is Rahimi
right
so there
Jones was a constructive approximation
Angela Dyson Perrin attributed the idea
to more evil woman okay the paranoia
system more and I don't know that this
theorem is I copied this from the
allerton paper but it's probably yeah I
mean it's definitely something is from
there okay
so right so functions of okay so in
other words you can approximate anything
of this integral form with with
something f hat which is finite and not
too big
assuming these norms are bounded here so
in so it's dense in the arc HS okay so
here's a potential proof strategy to
show things are learn about via SGD okay
so first let's make some assumptions of
our target because we want it we need
some assumption a reasonable one is to
say that it's approximately in the arc
HS induced by the kernel K or
approximable up to some epsilon not very
important so f star is in the arc HS and
has small arc AHS norm and the second
one is show that SGD learned something
as competitive as the best one in the
arc HS are normal
you can do these two things then you've
done very well because F star is
approximately an H and you've learned
something as well as the best in H this
is a it's sort of the agnostic case okay
so let's look how to execute step one or
we don't want to directly assume it's in
the arc HS we kind of want to show that
there's a family of polynomial ish
things in the RK HS so how to do this
most of the kernels we work with will be
core inner product kernels dot product
kernels so I can write Rho is just X dot
why it's gonna be a function of X dot
why I write this a series expansion
summation CI row I and then so I'm going
to pretend them in one dimension to save
notation and then you can see that you
can construct an explicit feature map
Phi of X sub I you just let it be square
root CI x to power of I okay so that's a
feature map so using this how do we
write down a polynomial in this as a
linear as a function this arc HS so
given some polynomial P of X with
coefficients PJ to the XJ power we want
to write it as linear in Phi right we
want to write it as W dot inner product
v you can just choose WJ to be PJ over
square root CJ so this is one way I've
now written a polynomial as a linear
function with respect to the feature map
of my arc HS okay so every polynomial
assuming C J's aren't 0 can be written
in something in a way like this
ok so now our KHS is dense but this is
when you study to pay attention to norm
because you may need exhumed and Norman
potentially even to start approximating
these polynomials if the CJS decay too
quickly so basically what matters here
is the arc HS norm is essentially the l2
norm of W so you don't want the l2 norm
of W to explode so it means if CJ's
decay too quickly then the outer normal
explode and you'll have huge of arc HS
norm and thus terrible sample complexity
so basically you either need PJ's to
decay very quickly or C J's to decay
very slowly or you know some combination
of the two okay so this is kind of the
ideas of step one is you can write
polynomials and probably other functions
too as linear functions in the arc HS it
doesn't have a shift invariant right
even if I wanted to do sampling I can't
promise unless you found the one norm of
the coefficients thank you yeah yeah
that's correct yeah so it doesn't align
with like the other kernels that you
talked about I mean it doesn't ever
random feet you can't just randomly
sample to get the approximation so you
were talking about earlier that's
correct
this one won't get
yeah there should be l1 Norma see yeah
yeah that's okay but to get the
representations that you want you're
gonna work with that to get the
reference in here yes that this one is
the two norm because I'm looking at the
RK chest or now okay right yeah I'm
going to work with two norms everywhere
okay
I because it's arcade yes okay okay yeah
so these polynomials can be written as
linear linear in the linear in the fight
in the in some feature map fight so
polynomials and I think you can make
this go through for others simplest
functions polynomials with fast enough
decaying coefficients are going to be in
RK chess so our analytic functions and
things like that if you as long as you
truncate their coefficient expansion so
step two remember step two is I want to
show that SGD learn something as
competitive as the best in the RK chess
okay the first thing that realizes
things are good if I restrict to to lair
this is a convex problem you so I
initialize just the W's on the sphere
then I minimize only over a foursome
square loss or hinge loss or whatever
okay so there's not going to be any
optimization issues here and I'll be
competitive mix when M is very very
large it's going to be competitive with
the best one the RHS it's something like
this except I think you're right that it
shouldn't be RK it should be l1 somehow
one measure here okay okay so let's
think about how to optimize two layers I
mean so we find already solve the
problem with one layer so it's a little
bit silly but we're talked about
optimizing both layers but and and you
can see that this is only really a
technical problem because the non
convexity is kind of harmless I mean we
don't need it to do anything right let
me you can just freeze it you can show
the learn it set the learning rate to
zero or very small and all of these
things are fine are going to work the
only thing we need to show is the
optimizing WJ doesn't hurt okay so how
is this done the first idea is to just
initialize a J's kind of smallish and
the norm of WJ to be order one then when
you look at the gradient of WJ it's very
small the gradient with respect to the
other parameter is the product sorry the
gradient of with respect to what what
the layer one parameter is the product
of other layers and so forth so if I
initialize other layers kind of small
then doubly aren't going to move very
much and as you can imagine when W
doesn't move at all the proof work so
when W still move you can bound things
and it's just perturbation at this point
okay
so the WS are not moving very much if I
initialize in a way like this okay and
again it so it's just compacts with
respect to a it's almost like you're
doing gradient descent on a convex
problem with except the features are
slightly moving but they're moving such
a small amount you can control this
movement and you're not using this
movement to get a better result or
anything okay so roughly speaking you
need to fix some target function and
yeah this should be one norm I don't
know should be one okay
all of these should be one norms not the
arcade adjustment but this this is
correct right okay so the number of
random features you need is not is wrong
there it's not the RK HS norm but the
bound is the arcade
okay yes oh yeah so you so we're going
to initialize so that somehow AJ is
smaller and scale than norm of hitting
unit WJ then even if you do SGD on both
parameter sets you're going to get
something divided by square root m so
this allows us to optimize both layers
yeah
I didn't say I'm thinking of
you're saying when will this work yes
certainly for rather missus I mean it's
pretty broad I mean there's going to be
standard smoothness type things like
yeah there's nothing very restrictive
here except the hell bar space changes
and then when the whole bar space
changes you need to make sure the
coefficients don't decay too quickly and
yeah put it on also March from any of
the discussions so rough or you just
have to part gold and somehow no no no
for example if this is like R a Lou
these C eyes okay you need to do some
small trick because the rather ones
vanish for some coefficients so you just
need to initialize in some asymmetric
way that's not quite Gaussian but you do
some small trick these C eyes are all
positive and you lower bound they're
decay and then you just construct
polynomials like this
so you're saying that by looking at the
expansion of the your activation
function you can if the indicate too
fast you will get in enough
approximation yeah that's right and
where's where is this explicit kind of
how what are the exact conditions to get
the outer norm of this thing is finite I
guess well to how one may be a quite not
l1 norm for the occasion and that's this
is which ones to will give you value or
paramo CI is like 1 over I squared I
think so you it they're all super -
they're all going to be yeah
so it depends on the activation I guess
yeah
even if AI is initialized to be small
here the optimization like the two layer
two layers become balanced right because
a is gonna get large gradients yes quite
so the top layer is getting more
gradients yes that's kind of the the
reason why it doesn't hurt to optimize
the hit in there right because a is
getting like you said a is getting order
1 gradients but this one is getting
order a great yes yeah but then they
become large and yeah but the rest is
already low already the risk is already
going to be small enough yeah and if
it's cross entropy you probably are at
least on or has one pass SGD there's
early stopping
it's exactly playing this trade-off
between the initialization sizes plays
into the learning rate and that
basically freezes alarm orally okay so
what is going on with deeper layers so
Danielle II noticed something similar
you simply just define Phi to be this
giant thing here so it's X superscript L
minus 1 is basically if I initialize all
my network weights are random and then I
pass it through the first L minus 1
layers and that's the output of that and
then that goes into the last hidden
layer so I can think of this now as a
random feature roughly speaking and that
induces some kernel KFI and similarly
what happens is that the initialization
is also so that the amount of movement
and w's is sort of bounded relative to
the movement in a so the A's are moving
faster in the sense so the kernel is
almost stationary and the kernel you get
is the one induced by this following a
feature basis
okay so to recap its if only the A's
change you're going to get a cardinal
that looks like this I'll call this kind
of the output kernel it's a little bit
unsatisfying is that you're not showing
you gain anything from optimizing the W
sorry but the fact that we optimized for
where a and that's the main thing that
we found the optimization where W does
it even mean that we cannot we can just
not optimize you don't need to optimize
Devon the bounce do not benefit from
optimizing W if I say def hurts a little
so we can just run this to you or a and
like yes in this these papers I'm
describing out where is this yeah
in this these papers by daniele and and
only that's basically the main idea does
you found the movement in the hidden
layer and it shows that you don't get
hard to buy at least some roll of the
doubts like that and the Cardinal I
didn't describe it because it's kind of
complicated this Cardinal changes with
depth and it's paying you're paying
different prices for higher order
coefficients when you go deeper it's not
very explicit
okay so if only yeah so the non
convexity is all in the W's and it's
kind of being fixed you're not
benefitting at all here's a slightly
more general viewpoint and now we're
starting to move into the regime of
neural tangent kernels which is imagine
that all of parameters are moving
roughly the same amount is you're still
going have a the prediction function of
theta as a taylor's is going to be a
linearization or Taylor's theorem like
this thing the important term is this
middle one is notice that this term is
linear in theta so imagine this was Phi
so this is now Phi dot theta minus theta
zero so again a linear function in theta
okay so for again neural nets for a
second let's think about any nonlinear
function you're going to pretend let's
pretend for now that the first F zero is
somewhat negligible it's roughly zero or
to order one and it won't affect things
too much it's just an offset I'll be at
the random one and the important term is
this linear term and then we're also
going to pick later on argue why the
second-order term is negligible and okay
so what happens here is you have this
linear term which is doing all the work
for you this is your feature map and
that's your predictor lead a minus theta
naught is your protector it turns out
that we'll see in a second that this
induces a cart this term corresponds to
a predictor in the are cages
here are some references the first group
they're grouped by their terminology
roughly speaking the first group calls
this a kernel method because this is
like linear in some feature embedding
and when the number of features is large
it concentrates or kernel the second
group of papers calls this
a pseudo network the idea is similar
they're sort of a the pseudo network is
sort of the it's a function that's
linear in the parameters and the way
it's defined is a gradient at the
initialization yes for just for the
kernel to concentrate otherwise it's
like a I mean I always have a carton
house I get to in a second yeah yeah
yeah I'll get to a second if I want to
analyze the kernel and say something
about the coefficients and whether
polynomials are in this space okay
okay so I'm going to take the Cardinal
viewpoint because it's a little bit
cleaner so let's so f theta is roughly
speaking if you believe me ignoring the
F zero and the second order term that
it's a linear function in nah blah blah
blah
f so my feature representation is Phi
which is the gradient with respect to
theta of F so if I have P parameters if
this is in P dimensions okay
what is good about F hat well it's a
linear method so that means it
corresponds to some kernel defined by
these inner products sorry this should
be K hi J is and this is Bob la fi na
blah FJ
okay so what does this neural oh sorry
people refer to this in the literature
as neural tangent car because it's
tangent because it's a gradient so it's
on the tangent space or whatever so it's
called the neural tangent kernel okay so
what do these neural tangent kernels
look like they generically look of the
following form they're going to so sorry
I change notation a little bit here my
network now has L hidden layers in the
output layer l plus 1 they're going to
be some linear combination positive
linear combinations of these que eles
and que eles are gradients with respect
to that layer of weights so for example
in the Tulare kernel I'm going to have
two kinds of two terms in the sum the
neural tangent kernel consists of the
first one this is the one used in
Daniels papers and also Rahimi erect is
that it's defined with the gradient with
respect to a k1 is now the gradient with
respect to W and you combine them with
some linear combination and I'll talk
I'll briefly say what the linear
combination comes from so is it clear
now what the kernel is they should all
be symmetric their kernel operators yeah
yeah I was just didn't see that from
if it's not yeah it's symmetric right so
this is Sigma prime of the scalar okay
yeah Sigma prime is the derivative of
activation
okay so you get some family of Cardinals
this neural tangent Colonel thing okay
so the this family of Colonels in fact
does include the earlier work on kernel
methods the kernel is initialization
dependent it really let's just look at
the two layer case it really matters how
the A's and WS are initialized for
example if the WS are initialized have
variance 1 over D and the A's are a
squared R 1 over m this would be lacunae
initialization and then if you treat M
going to infinity but input dimension is
fixed you are going to get K 2 only
because K 1 will be a vanishingly small
and then this will get back the kernel
using Daniela's work and Rahimi erect
okay in the literature more recently
there's a different parametrization
people refer to it as the NDK
parameterization and it's sort of things
are scaled like this notice what's
different is I explicitly pulled out a 1
over square root and when I wrote this
parameterization and now I'm going to
initialize the a J's as order 1 the norm
of W says order 1 input dimension is
treated as constant then the kernel I
get will be k1 plus k2
okay and this is what's done in these
papers for example you can also consider
a scaling when the a J's ro of one and
fixed and only trained the W's then of
course you'll only get k1 because you
don't ever take the grade if a is not
trained you don't take the gradient with
respect to a and that's what's done in
this paper by Li and Liang okay
and basically you can get the Alpha owls
by using different ratios of the width
because and then using lacunae
initialization or some of the standard
initializations and tweaking the ratio
of the widths or you could get different
alphas by their wise learning rates all
of these things will get you some
different way okay so basically NDK is a
family of these kernels and you can view
the previous works as looking at a case
where you only looked at k2 or more
generally in deep networks the gradient
only with respect to the output layer
for example this one is for a deep
network but if you look at the gradient
only with respect to the output layer
then it's outside this previous result
is the NDK where you only optimize
alquiler or somehow scale things so the
other layers don't matter
any questions here
okay so not as not he asked this is
always a cardinal what is going to
infinity so what's good what's going to
so now I'm going to initialize my layers
to be Gaussian and then when they're
Gaussian I can replace the inner product
with respect to an integral and
expectation and I'm going to get some
closed forms or K 1 and K 2 depending on
their variances these guys all have
closed forms this one this one has like
R cosine that has arc signs you can
write it down or assign as homework but
it's not that I don't have the equations
here at least to me they don't say too
much but they only depend on the angles
and the norms and if the inputs are
normalized they only depend on angles so
their dot product kernels okay
so that's for two layers how do i
compute these case when you start having
many layers right remember I need to
look at the expectation of this guy
where the gradient with respect to
middle layer and that starts getting a
little bit tricky luckily this has been
done in a few papers so basically the
idea is to always so the nish the first
idea is that if you're widths are all
infinitely large the X the input feature
times W is going to be a Gaussian
because central limit theorem if I
multiply it W times X and W is very very
big it's like m by DN m is like 10
billion that's going to be a Gaussian
process the input distribution has the
following covariance and then you can
recursively write down the covariance
function of this Gaussian process when
the width is very large so it's defined
by these two by two recursions you start
off with the input covariance and then
you recurse you define some two-by-two
matrix which is basically the covariance
it's basically the the two-by-two
covariance of the pre activation of the
previous layer and then now this is the
covariance with respect to the next
layer the pre activations of the next
layer well these guys showed us in
various different limits when in some
informal sense when M goes infinity the
notion of limits in all three papers is
different you get Sigma this Sigma sub L
is going to be KL plus 1 it's going to
be the kernel with respect to the output
layer weights
you know what I strongly suspect this
half of the slide was proved a long time
ago but not the latter huh although I
yeah let me talk about what the latter
houses yeah so this kind of Gaussian
process I think was the names that come
to mind would be like McKay and Williams
they had Gaussian process papers on for
neural nets and Radford Neil had things
like this or this first time oh is that
one okay yeah one hit in there okay
there you go
so yeah perhaps this is new to the
second half is definitely was not around
more than two year a year ago first sure
okay so the idea of the okay so this
tells you how to compute the gradient of
with respect to the output layer if you
want to do the middle there you
basically have to use the same Gaussian
process reasoning and combine it with
the backprop equations so what you're
going to do is instead of Sigma you're
also a define Sigma thought Sigma
thought is basically the covariances of
when you pass the pre activations
through the gradient and that's this
matrix here notice there's Prime's
everywhere now so that's the only
difference between this in this
and what these papers showed is that
case of owl so out this is now gonna be
an intermediate layer as you simply take
the output kernel of the one's the
inputs coming in so you should think of
this as X transpose X Prime and then the
product of all the earlier gradient
kernels in fact this looks exactly like
the backprop equations if you just think
about the backprop equations pretend
they were scalars and multiply them
together you would guess something as
Acme of this form okay so there is some
closed form for all of these things
that's only that's kind of the only
thing that's like to sing and you can go
on the computer and implement this
kernel okay so okay so now let me talk
about why gradient descent it will be in
fact close to this curve okay so recall
everything we are saying relies on some
form of Taylor's theorem or this
linearize network pseudo network sorry
so what needs to happen is that this
pseudo network sorry the linearized
network and the neural net are closed if
theta minus theta naught Knoll is small
you also certainly need F 0 to be
roughly order 1 otherwise if F 0
explodes faster than square root M then
gradient descent cannot stay close to
initialization because it needs to
cancel it so you need to initialize in a
way so F 0 doesn't blow up and I will
talk about that in one second ok let's
first talk about initialization size so
I have my post activations X sub L this
is my um my um my op 0 one very
important observation from this paper of
Lee and Lin is that when you initialize
a J's to be enough one over number
inputs so laocoon scaling you got 1 over
m the F 0 of X in fact will be order 1
why is that because of the cancellation
right because each of these guys is
roughly plus minus 1 over root m you add
a bunch of over 1 things they scale to
root admin that you divide by root m so
it's an order one quantity so by neuron
that although see me laying in the worst
case without this randomness could add
up to square root m the randomness
ensures f0 is very small so that's from
this paper by Lee and then it was used
later in other papers for the deep case
2 so the initialization is a square root
M smaller than what it could have been
in the worst case so why does this
matter because then it's exactly how
much you need to move this parameter to
forget your initialization
okay so here's some heuristic reasoning
for why gradient this these things will
be close so again I'm going to look at
my Jacobian what I want to do to solve
the Taylor expansion is to if the
cardinal method will exactly solve this
equation I have some Jacobian matrix
times theta minus theta no equal y minus
F 0 that's in fact if I want to solve
this equation I want to get this equal
to Y that's what the solution will look
like ok so what is the L 2 norm squared
of theta if I solve the kernel method so
it's simply given by this Y minus F 0 in
our product J transpose J inverse J
transpose J inverse is just the tangent
kernel inverse and doesn't depend on M
assuming again randomness comes in here
I'm using concentration ok so if M goes
to infinity and F 0 order of 1 as done
in these papers the amount you need to
move is constant with respect to M in
this of the width
the movement required in theta is o of
one okay so when is this prediction
going to be valid while you're thinking
order of one term then that means the
linearization and the original network
may start deviating a lot well to see
this we need to calculate the Hessian of
F theta if you calculate the house
universe data for any sized Network
you're roughly finding actually in fact
is going to 0 as a function of the width
roughly it's 1 over square root M
ignoring all things except with this one
here it suppresses anything that's not
with dependent let's just look at a tool
I now work with n TK parameterization if
you compute the Hessian with respect to
W J it's 1 over square root m times some
stuff this stuff is order 1 with respect
to the same thing on the cross term the
a jwj hessian and the gradient with
respect to aj is 0 it's linear it's you
know it's a linear function J okay so
the curvature vanishes as the width
increases our prediction function and
it's linearization when you have very
large with well in a constant radius at
least will always agree with the
linearization because the Hessian is
vanishing this isn't how the papers
write it but this is at the end of the
day this is what's happening is they the
papers do some perturbation bounce on
this hessian j but really what's
happening is that the j is not changing
because the function is flat
okay
so what does this mean for the training
dynamics since you can make the
curvature now arbitrarily small you can
now bound the gradient flow dynamics on
the linearize network on one side I'm
doing kernel gradient descent on the
other side I'm doing gradient descent on
the neural net function and I can bound
these two things so I this is gradient
descent on the kernel at time T this is
gradient descent on the network at time
T there's something warder of the
hessian and again ignoring all things
with independent not depending on the
width it's something like 1 over root
down so by tuning up the width i make
the function flatter and then these two
things are closer and closer so you just
did the this perturbation analysis of
how j changes is not actually necessary
yeah you can get a shorter proof this
way I think I'm pretty sure yeah
for a different proof I don't know if
it's easier yeah but more conceptually
clear yeah what energies can behind it
like this oh that's a good question
anything smooth can be handled via these
these you know in formal arguments one
of these papers do where is it these all
three of these papers do do non smooth
things but then the arguments are not
this compact
yeah but I would say the activations not
important here it's you can almost get
all of the main ideas just by thinking
of it as general nonlinear functions
almost okay so what I've argued now is
the linic the kernel gradient descent
and the neural network preed produce
similar trajectories prediction
functions at up to time T so what have
people use this to prove this has been
used to prove that using Laocoon
initialization but the to learn network
will converge to a global minimizer if
you use very very small step size that's
in these papers here similar arguments
were used in deep nets convolutional
deep nets ResNet so forth basically most
of the kinds of nets people use what
they basically do is exactly this
argument they try to make these two
things close this numerator as something
nasty on top and then they just make em
big enough to cancel the numerator
that's basically the idea the
dependencies are bad there are at least
n squared most of them are worse the
best one in the list is N squared
yeah it's we come from what's the what
would what live it Julie what's the
numerator
it comes from morally you want like a
spectral norm here but when you're doing
the perturbation you can't quite get it
the perturbation spectral norm so you're
doing something loose like the Frobenius
norm and then you're picking up
dimension factor where the dimension of
the Hessians n-by-n I think that's
roughly where it's coming is you're
trying to bound entries or rows or
columns of the this the way J changes
and the or J transpose J and instead of
some spectral norm thing you're using
something that what's not quite the
spectrum I think that's right I don't
think the widths are very important
either I think because they're all worst
case for you know the worst case labels
you can do significantly better as soon
as you start assuming things about wire
okay so this is what people so people
have used this machinery to analyze
training air again we can ask the
question is what functions can be
efficiently learned if we use these
neural tangent kernels okay so like so
again the K is one of our induced
kernels the sample complexity of
learning with respect to kernel is the
RK chess norm squared over epsilon
squared so again we can try to do this
trick of writing the linear these
functions these functions as so
everything as functions linear in the
feature map Phi so again with their dot
product Carnales you can just simply
Taylor expand and then for example if
you had a monomial of degree K you can
write f of X as some inner product of a
vector UK with Phi and the 1 over CK
will enter the coefficient so if this
thing is decaying very quickly you're
paying a lot for the polynomial if it's
decaying very slowly you pay very little
so the same thing I already talked about
before so that's in the kernel space you
can do something similar for general
polynomials sort of the same argument
you can work out the RHS norm is going
to be a J squared over CJ where a J is
the coefficients of the polynomial and
the same thing the same ideas work for
the multivariate case so basically well
you can learn as a constant degree
polynomial of degree K with sample
complexity like 1 over c k4 to learn
networks you can work out this
explicitly the form of the kernel DK is
like 1 over J squared so you're going to
need summation ei J squared J squared
less than infinity
so the coefficients need to for this to
be finite the coefficients in ATK faster
than geometric for sure okay so people
have used essentially this kind of
reasoning to start analyzing teacher
networks here I was talking about
polynomials it's not too far to go from
a polynomial to a teacher network with
very smooth activations so now think
about Sigma where the activation
function is very very smooth meaning it
has a has a Maclaurin series and then
things decay nicely like you're actually
has a pair of squared loss yeah I was in
thesis I was thinking square I lost my
house
not all this that's that's correct yes
that this argument is not directly from
any of these papers but it might be
wrong too yeah coming the second
complexity so you said it'd be full of
eels we've pressed up to tailor the
world using these diverse materials you
can you comment abilities deceitful
hooks T versus the I don't know what the
min/max
the minimax rate use I don't know the
minute
Sasha Sasha doesn't give a sense of I
mean you're doing as well as Colonel
Richard
okay no it's not that in fact I will
show you a kernel that's better I think
I have it here Eric I'm not concerned
about the one over square ever consider
what the numerator yeah yeah yeah I got
you're concerned about this
okay so how to go from this to teacher
networks is quite straightforward
actually is you simply expand the the
activation as in terms of it as a
polynomial expansion and then you just
collect terms whatever and you get now
something that looks like a polynomial
maybe you need a truncate cuz it's
analytic and not a polynomial okay so
this is where to learn networks and
there's a similar recursive argument
similar to what I did in the earlier
paper to make this work for deep
networks similar idea you just apply the
feature map twice you recurse the
feature map and then you write a linear
thing in the recursion table okay so
these papers Aurora at all use this to
show for two layered networks when this
activation is appropriately decaying
coefficients and TK can learn it
Alan zhu-li and Liang used not this
argument they directly constructed a
pseudo network which is essentially this
Phi thing I was talking about so they
constructed a pseudo network and they
showed that teacher networks with smooth
activations can be written as a pseudo
network meaning morally it's basically
Phi inner product something theta is
this pseudo network instead of this
series expansion argument cowan code and
Yeley showed similar things you can
learn some arc HS via a deep network oh
yeah and here's the other kernel that
naughty was saying so none of this is
really leaving the regime of this kernel
defined by straight RN at all which is
basically this it's like all polynomial
kernel it's like you just get all the
monomials and then for example in that
Cardinal you would get
you can learn all of these teacher nuts
too and you you need a Riccar set for
the deep voice okay you know how the
some complexity or like this goes down
towards the kernel or under the bed
suppose mr. Pennell compared to the
complicated curve you can work it out I
don't know it right now yeah
I don't know it's computable sure I mean
the question is are these fences
actually decent methods for learning
polynomials or are they really horrible
methods that are still I'm not sure I
doubt they're the best there doesn't say
correctly that when you're talking about
not having to move very far from the
initialization that's because you're
reaching a point that has that fits it
up perfectly or I have that yes we're
square loss yes but I'll discuss this in
one minute oh so it wasn't it wasn't a
requirement of the earlier result
available for square loss you run it for
all timing and from other losses you are
at least on that's the short times are
about discuss why this is necessary so I
guess on this slide I was asking about
this is the teacher network is this is
this in a noisy classroom
none of these papers happy noise this
noise I see i imagine if it's additive
id know is you early stop it's fine but
I think none of these hot noise okay
sort of related to Peters question is
how does the loss function come in here
so let's look at the case for square
loss for M large enough some finitely
large Amazon o then F hat T the
linearized network and F key are closed
something divided by root F for all time
T so you can take infinite time and this
is exactly so this is on the train loss
and this is exactly because the you're
perfectly fitting the data and the air
is doing the zero for logistic loss you
can't quite get this if you compute it
with Lacuna initialization you're going
to get for all time key roughly until
the logistic loss is a value one over m
so you cannot run for infinite time you
for a finite width you can run for a
certain amount
if you want to run for a longer time you
need the width to be longer for this
agreement but this is interesting in
another line of work that Mackey will
talk about in the afternoon is for very
large time so we don't know how long
though we know it for you
asymptotically that it's not going to be
a kernel predictor and so there's some
intermediate regime this result is from
when the logistic loss is like zero
basically super small and this one was
far as one over m and then there's some
big regime in the middle we don't quite
know what happens Mackey will talk about
this I think it afternoon the other
interesting case to think about is when
you do SGD one pass s to D with fresh
data right because now you can't ever
stop and they'll start differing at some
point so first for very small time T if
you do SG d on the kernel method then SG
d on the network they'll agree and then
at some point they'll start differing
and we don't know yeah we don't know
what happens to us G D on the network
when they start different we only know
this initial phase and at some point
they start different that's in this
paper by May and Monta Mary in there
cause okay so the kernel regime holds
for the Train loss with square loss
forever with logistic loss on the
training loss for some amount time until
you bet the one over m and then you
start some intermediate thing and then
eventually asymptotically we know what
happens then if it's one pass SVD we
know for a short amount of time and then
afterwards we don't know
okay let me talk about learning rate
okay so I didn't mention learning rate
at all and all of those earlier papers
set the learning rate at the end and
they said is small enough to get the
behavior they want but and and the
learning rate is very much connected to
what parameterization uses and it's it's
PI subtle okay imagine what FA what I'll
call the standard parameterization it's
just a to learn network with no pre
multipliers and FB which other people
call the N key K parameterization notice
I pulled out the 1 over square root m to
make it explicit the standard
initialization mccune for example is w
is i 1 over D and a is 1 over m so
notice under this initialization scheme
F at time zero returns order 1
quantities so f 0 sub a is gonna be zero
order 1 and key K I since I pull out the
scaling here I need to initialize the
A's a little bit differently now I'm
going to initialize them to be normal 0
1 both of these initializations ensure
that F 0 of X is order 1 and parametrize
the same functions I mean you just
divide the W's by something right and
it's
yeah but I'm creating input dimensions
fixed - yeah that's why I thought about
that last night okay so these two things
in fact will get the same gradient flow
path but when you start talking about
gradient descent they start differing
let's look at if you do gradient descent
on model a with a constant learning rate
that corresponds using a learning rate
that's M times bigger on the ndk
parameterization so basically what this
means is it is important it was crucial
in these NPK proofs that you set the
learning rate 1 over m times smaller all
of those papers used eita
order 1 which corresponds to an
infinitely small learning rate on the
standard parametrization but so in
practice if you use wide resonance with
bigger and bigger multipliers and you
keep your learning rate roughly constant
or at least not decreasing 1 over m then
Behnke K will not be a good
approximation okay so essentially when
you have infinite width and you want to
use a constant learning rate you will
immediately leave this kernel know
regime in one step essentially okay so
the inside the parametrization is hiding
a learning rate scaling in the sense
okay oh wow that's dense okay so now let
me start talking about some limitations
of these Cardinal methods so there's a
so for example if my target function is
a single relu then you actually need
exponentially many random features to
approximate this method for this for the
output kernel this yahoodi' and Samir
show this so then on the other hand so
what this also means is that you can
imagine they didn't direct I don't know
if they directly prove this but means if
I initialize my model as here but
imagine there were plus minus ones here
then if you use gradient descent you
would have trouble learning this unless
you had a ton of random features however
if we use a different model and these
coefficients are all positive and then
you do gradient descent only on the
doubloons you're going to converge to W
star with only order D samples so
there's somewhat of a gap here is that
as soon as I initialize at random the
evidence points are you need a ton of
samples potentially exponentially but
then if I fix the signs correctly I get
its learn about with D samples so a
single relu if you try to learn it with
this sort of an TK analysis you would
fail terribly another negative result if
I only have dimension to the K number of
random features I can only learn as well
as fitting a degree K polynomial so
essentially if you want to learn better
than a polynomial you need a ton of run
better than a polynomial degree five you
need a ton of random features so it's
saying that it's kind of hinting the arc
HS norm is very big or something
okay
and then here's another negative result
where is this citation okay it's okay
the citation of my own paper so no one
will get mad so there's a simple
distribution it's essentially a
distribution realizable by for a loose
constant number of Ray loose and then if
you had less than d squared samples your
zero one test error using any of the
kernels any of the N key case no matter
what you tuned the coefficients there's
no better than random guessing so in
some sense the idea here is that the our
KHS inductive bias is very poorly
aligned with targets that are sparse in
your on the space for example in this
first example your target was a one
sparse thing in this bottom example it's
a for sparse thing by sparse I mean you
write it f star the target as an
integral with respect to measure and
then this row is small and l1 norm is
what I mean by small so for example when
you have one neuron is just a single
Dirac Delta function in this other model
is for Delta functions and roughly
speaking the arc HS inductive bias is
the l2 norm of Rho and but you're trying
to learn a function of small now one
norm and you're paying so you're paying
a ton so if you could learn with respect
to l1 of Rho I'm not saying I know an
algorithm that can in polynomial time if
you could though your sample complexity
is linear in deep and if you use the
kernel methods is at least d squared
like this they heard about like the
facility or of the lay about know the
linearised carnal expressive it's a
statement about the expressivity it's
not about the solutions you will find
it's a statement about if you do SGD on
the linearize predictor and they saying
that will do no better than learning a
polynomial of degree k unless your
number of random features is much larger
whereby learning a polynomial you're
just like i guess maybe you're hoping
yeah yeah I'm gonna know me or something
yeah low bots are there sort of fur
corresponding empirical results that
show that this is actually not a problem
like the same training whatever with
gradient descent on the same
distribution actually thus sexy
sorry have check except for these lower
bounds do you have these person first in
the third points are there sort of
empirical result that show that well you
can know we have experiments that do
show actually does poorly here okay for
this simple distribution it's basically
X or in two dimensions and then other
dimensions are calcium so okay so so so
in that sense you could say whatever n
TK then does capture well what AHA but
if you mess around with the learning
rates and things then that it's not
clear with your learning rate is tiny
yes but when the learning rate starts
becoming bigger than it's not so clear
that it can learn it
in network can provably hopefully
provably or at least convincingly
empirically learn something that is
perfectly not learn the bull with a
reasonable number of samples using the
tension Pro there's that right right
that's well I will let me spin away with
whether any of those I'm not sure but I
would be pretty surprised if you cannot
learn the single rules if you start
using regularization and over and then I
mean you I mean you I know for example
if you write this you can learn it I
mean there are distribution on some
which really will not be learn about
yeah for this one where the employers
Gaussian and it's realized by a single
target I know it okay so this is one
example where it is learn about by SGD
but it's just the initialization scheme
is different I don't know of one where
the initialization scheme is matches the
ndk and the only thing you're allowed to
vary is like learning rates although I
would guess there exists
didn't take the initialization scheme
this works definitely pension
confidential agency yes is it little
with them no oh no but this kernel is
like degenerate because of scaling
issues that's the
it's gonna add up and it's gonna blow up
yeah yeah it's fine not if I miss
infinity in this scale okay so if you
fix it I find out with the tangent
kernel for this will not learn it yeah
for this one even when this yeah it
won't learn SGD will learn this because
this tangent kernel doesn't matter if
there's an e JS the a J's gets squared
so there one the tangle kernels the same
in this parameterization up to scalish
and the tangent kernel fails for the
single rather and mady's this paper by
certain al-kitabi uses a very different
it uses one point convex which uses
gaussian of the some gaussian data and
some other things
okay so how'd it go beyond NTK so what
follows is not math it's more opinions
than anything else so of course an
interesting question to ask here is the
kernel regime reflecting the success of
deep learning so there the nd case don't
do too badly like this paper shows they
s7d 77 or 78 percent C for 10 but on the
same architectures when they do SGD the
accuracy was higher I think was 80
something 85 or so and that's nothing's
changed they just did SGD versus learn
the kernel they computed the kernel
exactly
and then they implement it too I looked
at the test accuracy so there's a gap
it's like 7 8 % something like that and
so can we close this gap I mean and how
so here are some thoughts the learning
rate is definitely important if you use
a small learning rate then you will see
that n TK and SGD find similar
predictors but in this regime the test
accuracy of both is pretty bad with the
same architecture and the learning rate
is better and that's what I think this
Aurora paper did the test accuracy is
higher there was 7 or 10 percent higher
roughly in that paper so and then of
course when you're using n TK you're
implicitly enforcing your learning rate
to be infinitely small basically which
might hurt learning so perhaps there's a
way where you can set the learning rate
initially to be large move the kernel
away from the kernel parent kernels are
completely data agnostic right they're
defined only with respect to random
initializations once you start doing SGD
these kernels are somehow adaptive data
I don't I mean I can write an equation
but I don't know why they're adapting
well but perhaps you can show you to
better here's a more concrete example if
you try to solve matrix completion with
the following predictor so the samples
now are just the IJ observed entries so
there's only n d squared possible
samples so your observation pattern is
you V transpose
the ijn created right so this is a
perfectly valid predictor if you compute
so now like you and VP Gaussian of size
D by Emma and where I'm going to take m
to go to infinity so I'm going to do
matrix matrix completion with over
parameterize factors for some weird
reason now what you can ask the question
what will n TK do it turns out that n TK
will simply impute the observed entries
it's going to do the kind of stupidest
thing ever if there was an observation
there in the loss like oh why IJ it
fills in Y IJ if it wasn't and there was
no term of that loss it fills in 0 or
sorry sorry nozzle it just leaves it at
the random initialization and then in
these asymptotic calculations it's kind
of suggestive that if you run GD for a
very long time then you will get minimum
nuclear nor the first one is sort of
like minimum Frobenius norm -
initialization hopefully so very very
different inductive biases is that you
can see in one example already is you
kind of rather be in this case so again
coming back to this logistic loss that
not he's going to talk about we know
that asymptotically you're going to get
a stationary point of this max margin so
max margin with respect to L 2 norm of
parameters shown in these two papers
here for even simple models oh and
notice n ki K is generally not a
stationary point it's auntie K solutions
not max margin not a stationary point of
this maximum for even simple models
already out to regularization on
parameters gives in duck interesting
inductive biases for example for deep
linear nuts you get the shot into over L
norm so closer and closer low rank if I
write a linear model as a Hadamard
product of two vectors that inductive
bias becomes an l1 norm for two lara lou
networks if i do L 2 norm on the
parameters it's an l1 norm on the
measure so I'm trying to learn networks
that are sparse in neurons
bass & 4d Prelude networks you can't
quite write down this as a nice thing
like this but you get some size free
complexity bound so kind of it's kind of
too much to expect that you always get
global max margin except in like matrix
completion matrix sensing but perhaps
you can somehow interpolate between n TK
and this global max margin so one
concrete question is if I initialize at
the end key K solution the West
stationary point of this max margin do
you go to because I know if I run
explore unlit gradient this out on
logistic loss then in the beginning for
a very long time if I initialize very
wide then for a very long time I stay in
the kernel regime so it's basically like
I'm going to converge to some stationary
point worth I starting at the end key K
solution so what basin of Attraction is
the antique a solution in and I think
that's all I have
here we are thankful couple more
questions so what's the day learning
scale infinity is it's one over with
smaller
if you want to use a constant learning
rate in this parameterization you need a
sorry if you use a constant learning
rate in NDK it's eita over m in the
standard so it's infinitely small
learning
okay if there is no more question let's
sign Jason again we need